[Music]
thank you
all right so just got to the office and
I'm in a meeting room now let me just
put my stuff down
hey everyone this is Lucy I'm a
Solutions architect working at AWS and
today I'll be showing you what a day in
my life looks like a lot of people have
been asking about you know what do I
really do as a Solutions architect what
does a typical day look like and so
today is not going to be a typical day
but it's probably a typical Thursday for
me because Tuesday Wednesday Thursdays
we have a lot of customer meetings
Mondays for internal meetings Fridays
more for our own learning sharpening the
saw is what we call it there's a few
things planned on the calendar as I
mentioned I have two customer meetings I
have a one-on-one with someone in my
team and then at five o'clock we have a
early careers barbecue so this will be a
great chance to catch up with some of
the early careers people in my team and
outside the team as well I find that on
the days I have my custom meetings it
feels like the whole day just goes by
really quickly but I thought I'd take
you along my day try to record bits and
pieces where I can so yeah let's jump
straight in into it
[Music]
[Music]
alright so I've just had my first
customer meeting of the day and this
discussion was around the customers
databases they are self-hosting their
databases but they'd like to bring it on
to AWS what I have to do now is I'm
going to be writing a follow-up email
just to send them through the links and
recommendations that we discussed in the
core
foreign
[Music]
now it's time for lunch and I'd like to
take a moment to introduce today's video
response on Lord pass I don't know about
you but I find it really hard to
remember all the passwords to the
accounts I create lordpass offers a
secure password management tool and the
no pass business password manager makes
it easy for you to store and manage
passwords the platform helps ease the
burden of access to business accounts
making it possible for you and your team
to work across devices and apps
uninterrupted as we go into the admin
view you can see that there are options
to invite additional team members
observe password security create groups
and check user activity I've started to
store my own passwords on nordpass to
save me the hassle of having to press
the forgot password button every time I
can't remember my credentials see
nordpass business in action now with a
three month free trial by clicking the
link in the description below and using
the code Tech with Lucy now let's get
back to the video
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys what's up welcome to the snack
tour
do you want to say something we've got
really cool stuff we've got chips we've
got Tim Tam it's got nuts and we've got
more nuts so this is where we come and
snacks and talk about what we're doing
during our day
um if you know we're feeling a little
sleepy we'll get a little coffee like
And subscribe to see more Tech with Lucy
content
what she said
thank you
[Music]
hold me close till I get up time is
[Music]
all we'll ever trust
we'll go